ein letztes Mal goodbye um 17 Uhr 48
deutscher Zeit wird der Sarg von Königin
Elisabeth II in die Gruft hinab gelassen
nun ist sie wieder mit ihrem geliebten
Ehemann Prinz Philip der im vergangenen
Jahr starb vereint bei der Trauerfeier
in Essen georgekapelle auf Schloss
Winzer nahmen rund 800 gästeteil es ist
ein Jahrhundert Ereignis mit Blumen
verziert ist hier der Sarg ein letztes
Mal zu sehen bevor er in die königliche
Gruft unter der Kapelle hinuntergelassen
wird
besonders beeindruckend Queen eliz Biff
saß rund 70 Jahre auf dem britischen
Thron sie liebte ihr ganzes Leben in der
Öffentlichkeit
ihren letzten Abschied feierte nun mit
ihrem Liebsten genauso wie sie es sich
gewünscht hat
je nach Folge ist nun ihr Sohn König
Charles der dritte
[Musik]